-Today is Friday.
That's usually when I catch up
on some personal stuff.
I check my inbox.
I return some emails
and, of course,
I send out thank-you notes.
[ Cheering and applause ]
And I was just
running a bit behind,
so I thought,
if you guys wouldn't mind,
I'd like to write out my weekly
thank-you notes right now.
Is that alright with you guys?
[ Cheering and applause ]
Thank you.
James, can I get some thank-you
note writing music, please?
[ Playing tender tune ]
[ Laughter ]
-Tireless fighter.
-Yeah.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you,
A$AP Rocky's cape
at the Met Gala,
for finally answering
the question,
"What if you could wear
Crunch Berries?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Wahoo.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you, people who wear
their masks around their elbows,
for telling the world
that you're responsible,
but also like pretty chill.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-"Anh, I'll put it on
if I need it."
-"Whatev."
Oh, mask?
Okay.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you, tandem sky diving,
or as I like to call you,
ultimate baby bjorning.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Let's do this!"
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Thank you,
Marriott and Hilton Hotels,
for guaranteeing that,
whatever room you book,
you get a breathtaking view
of the parking lot.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Cheering ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, "The Price Is Right"
celebrating its 50th season,
for showing us that,
even after five decades,
no one in America really knows
how much things cost.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I don't know, $1.50?
[ Applause ]
-$10,000.
I don't know.
-$10,001?
[ Laughter ]
Okay.
-You can't assume.
-Now they're hacking the system.
Come on.
[ Laughter ]
Alright, here's the last one.
Here we go.
-Of what?
-Let me see.
-Oh, thank-you notes.
[ Laughter ]
Just riff one, man.
Just go wild.
-Just riff a thank-you note?
-Just riff
a thank-you note.
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Suspenseful music plays ]
♪♪
[ Tapping ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Got one? Got it?
-Yeah.
This one is about space.
[ Laughter ]
I'll riff one.
-Okay. Alright.
[ Tender tune plays ]
-Thank ye --
-[Both] "Thank ye."
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
[ Ding ]
-Oh, with an "E," yes.
-Not bad.
-Yeah.
-Hear ye, hear ye.
Thank ye, thank ye.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Thank you,
Nicki Minaj's cousin's friend --
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
Sorry to leave you hanging.
[ Laughter ]
There you go, everybody.
Those are my thank you notes.